this is a production of Cornell
University welcome back to week six can
you believe we've been locked up for six
weeks already you can talk to my family
if you want to know more about details
with that okay welcome uh yeah you know
guys are really I got this from a
British groundskeeper the other day who
sent it around we're so glad that you
can be with us we hope that you're safe
we hope that these things continue to
inform you maybe distract you maybe help
you do things better in these enormous
ly difficult times so so and of course
in New York's Goods good New York style
right who doesn't like a good New York
saying you know as you're entering one
of the many bridges and tunnels that
traverse the New York metropolitan area
so again big shout out to our brothers
and sisters in the New York metropolitan
area where those of us in New York know
particularly that it's you know
currently hitting the hardest still so
so good luck in and especially for the
lawn and landscape crews that are out
there trying to work safe I'm not going
to waste a lot of time with getting
through much of growing because I want
to hear from Joe Allen about ticks and I
want to talk to you about what we've
been learning and revisiting something
oddly enough I did in my graduate work
over over 30 years ago now so it's funny
how things come back around but let's
start with soil temperature this is what
it was like about 3-4 weeks ago when we
got together and it looked like in early
April everybody was going to run out and
put the preeminent is somewhere in the
55 degrees soil temperature range which
we'll talk about that in a minute and
I'm not even worried necessarily about
when it happens I want to talk about the
way it happens today but if you looked
at this map back then and wasn't paying
attention to the forecast or was you
know nervous about being locked down and
went out and put your pre-emergent
herbicides they would have basically
sat there for three weeks with virtually
no maybe leaching through a little bit
maybe breaking down a little bit
especially in urban areas where the heat
island effect can take over but really
soil temperatures didn't progress very
much you had a lot of time from the
early sort of trigger we use to even
where we are now and we're not expecting
to see this change dramatically we're
way behind normal we're gonna catch up a
little bit this week right but when you
look at weed control in general right
we're still you know this is for the 6th
of May this is five days from now we're
expecting broadly if we control you know
roughly about a hundred and fifty base
50 growing degree days that we
accumulate since March first right
basically we're not gonna see that again
for a little while alright we've talked
about growth potential and we've learned
a lot this week of anybody that joins us
for all of these things is getting quite
a turf grass education these days we had
Doug sold out with us for the Golf
Course superintendent's Association of
New York symposium talking for about 40
minutes about nitrogen and turf grass
growth and and while he likes growth
potential as an annual model doesn't
really like it for a sort of daily or
weekly model and they're developing
models about how grow a grass grows but
here's what we know weather drives it
you can put as much fertilizer on it as
you want you could dump the whole bag in
a particular area it'll likely burn it
but it won't really get growing until
the weather conditions are right we were
very interested to see how little soil
nitrogen and applied nitrogen mattered
for growth of grass versus relative
humidity temperature and other factors
all right JoEllen before I get to my
crabgrass conversation with that as a
backdrop and with really not much
evolving moving forward this coming week
you want to talk to us a little bit as
we get out and about and you know this
is important in the lawn and landscape
area as you share your screen and maybe
the lifecycle because we've got some
information now that says piling leaves
along the edge of the woods you know is
a better tick habitat not surprisingly
now that's maybe one particular tick so
as people venture out let's talk a
little bit about where ticks are right
now and and what you're expecting sue
okay so I am going to share my screen
and you mentioned that there is more
than one type of tick which is something
that we absolutely have to keep in mind
so Carl I don't think that I can do this
yet Carl you gotta make her a co-host I
think yeah you are a co-host John can
you see okay so what I'm showing you
here the vortex that we're really
worried about in New York right now is
the black legged tick also known
obviously as the deer tick the American
dog takes the Lone Star tick in the
Asian longhorn tick so so up here I have
this table that shows when you these the
different life stages of these are going
to be most active so here we are at the
beginning of May and pretty much
everything can be out there right now
but what we're most worried about are
the black legged tics because those are
the ones that can transmit Lyme disease
which is the most common tick borne
pathogen that we have out there so we
have the adults we've had a mild winter
so the adult black legged takes are
pretty much active up until now at some
point soon they're going to run out of
energy and they're going to start dying
off because they don't have enough
energy to continue on but right now
research has shown that they are
desperate because they want to find that
final blood meal and meat and that drive
is very strong so they are their energy
has been kicked into high gear and they
also are going to take more risks so
we're more likely to find adult black
legged ticks and areas wouldn't normally
find them such as in the middle of our
lawns
just following carbon dioxide and other
clues looking for something but now is
also the time that the black legged take
nips come out so this is the second life
stage they're the size of poppy seeds
and they have had one blood meal so
there is a chance that they could be
carrying the pathogens that cause these
diseases and because they're so small
we're at a higher risk of coming into
contact with them bit by them because
we're not looking for them and there's
still this thought that ticks are a
summer issue so ticks are not on
people's radar screens so right now
we've got the nymphs and the black
legged takes and that's really the only
ones that I've gotten people reporting
to me that they've been finding out
there but as you can see from this chart
the American dog ticks are also becoming
active and for those downstate we have
the Lonestar ticks and the Asian
long-horned ticks that can get going
this is going to be an interesting year
because so many of us are shut down and
they'll be able to do our fieldwork so
we're going to not be as up-to-date with
what these other tick species are doing
as we might normal years okay yeah
they're gonna be mostly the blackleg
attacks are going to be near the woods
and in the leaf litter so if you have
leaf litter piled up along your woodland
edge that's a really good project for
you to take on and to offer to your
clients to get rid of those leaves
because that will reduce tick habitat so
what about you know listen we've chatted
about this many times you and I publicly
privately there's two issues one is
there doesn't seem to be anything better
than personal protection and reviewing
your body after you think
you've been in areas or even outside now
that we've learned ticks are such risk
takers who knew second people asked
about treating a lot of a lot of people
offer services for treating we could
spend another half an hour talking about
those two particular topics but
certainly protection Extreme as treated
clothing watching you know cleaning
yourself dealing with your clothes that
seems to still be the best thing but
people still offer the treatment so you
want to just take a minute and talk
about balancing those two things
sure so there's been a lot of research
that has been done on treatment this was
some work that we funded that was taken
up by Suffolk County and they were
looking at different products that were
out there including natural products and
comparing it to the more traditional
pesticides that we would use there's a
lot of numbers here what I want you to
really notice is that on the on the left
hand side this is the lab work so this
is where you take your ticks and you put
pesticides directly on them and you can
see even with the more natural products
the essentia isee-3 which is a lot of
plant essential oils and cedar safe
which is cedar oil we have some pretty
high numbers there for control whether
eighty eight percent is good enough I
don't think so because it only takes one
to give you a pathogen so when you take
that so same products let me take them
out into the field and we apply them in
a way that you would with your sprayer
on the environment those numbers go much
much lower so it goes from a hundred
percent control with black legged tick
nips with Telstar and then it goes down
to 65 percent when we go out into the
field and then if we're talking about a
different type of tick for Lonestar text
which is the Americana there those
numbers go down even farther so knowing
what you have what life stage you're
trying to treat is very important
also research has shown that going out
and killing 72% of the ticks that are
out there is not going to protect people
from tick borne diseases so you can go
out and treat it's going to reduce your
risk but boy you've got to tell your
clients that they still need to do
personal protection because it's not
100% guaranteed permease retreated
clothing you mentioned that that's kind
of extreme actually it is the best thing
that you can do and it's on your
clothing as opposed to things like deep
that you're putting onto your skin which
if it's your fear celebrating nude
gardening day or highly recommend the
premies untreated clothing so you know I
was talking to Bob Evans many people
know Bob as our old professor at SUNY
Cobleskill retired you know 15 16 years
now still active and busy and Maine and
Maine is a hot spot especially coastal
Maine is a hot spot for ticks and he
said to me we were chatting about this
and he said to me what you said there he
goes I spray my clothes so regularly
with permethrin I don't even really
notice it anymore because he lives in
the woods they live in the woods in
Maine and the risk is high so yes it may
not be extreme I think it is the
discussion we need to have it may
everything may reduce your risk there's
no zero risk right that's why checking
yourself and being protected is so
important
absolutely okay so let's leave it at
that also protecting your pets as well
their pets are coming inside and they're
bringing the ticks with them so talk
here that find out what their
recommendations are and follow their
advice inter-pass protective well all
right now you brought it up I put a spot
on my dog's back neck doesn't that help
me for ticks yes well it depends on the
product Oh still check your pets but
make sure that you're putting some kind
of protection on them on the advice of
your veterinarian yes I mean I've got
two dogs that are just walking tick
magnets if they go anywhere near it
when you're I think their data usually
with at least what we treat them with
and I'm not a vet or any of those things
but I listen especially if you let your
dog on your bed your dog on your couch
your dog in your chair you hug your dog
you ride in a car with your dog all
those places is where the tick goes yes
Joelle absolutely and they're happy to
jump off how this was in my bed it was
dead any comment on my cat but it's very
disturbing okay let me have the screen
back we'll talk about things before this
gets gross and you know Joella now I
hate the gross pictures you show in your
presence yes I know and I uploaded those
today thank you for you all right all
right so listen let's let's chat about
crabgrass here and see if there's any
questions in this area as well as we
move forward all right we are in the
time when crabgrass you know as I was
putting this together I'm like okay I
don't want to have a broad I don't want
to talk more than 10 15 minutes because
we knew we're gonna have Joelle and like
talk about the weather so I started
looking at all right how do I want to
talk about emergence of weeds in the
springtime right now you can run a
gammon on this right certainly we're
learning now still gratis is emerging
some people call I believe I heard
someone refer to still pass as the as
crabgrass in the shade
Japanese still crest that is the it
seems to be a growing pest problem in
the metropolitan New York area seems to
germinate a little bit earlier that's at
least what we hear but we also hear that
it sometimes terminates later at least
that's what we hear crabgrass comes in
both smooth and large-format smooth is
very common along the coast as you move
inland and into the Midwest you tend to
see more large but smooth crabgrass by
many of the surveys we published back 30
years ago is the predominant crabgrass
we find in the lawns in most of the
northeastern United States you south and
west ago you get more large and then
there's goose grass which comes up
even later maybe two to three weeks
later depending on the condition the
turf is in and Andy and the the soil
temperature and the way is exposed in
the weather conditions so in general it
works still grass and then crabgrass and
then and then goose grass and then this
kind Lyngen is all obviously many things
emerge but most of what emerges that
we're dealing with are annuals to some
degree that are gonna go through the
summer grow flower and die now still
grass is a little bit different than
that but in general coastal grass you
know it's a c4 plant it's one of those
odd plants that is a warm season plant
but tolerates low light we wonder as
this thing emerges the kind of sense it
might make for us moving forward anyway
the long and the short of it is you know
we think of emergence as a distinct
event and I want to talk a lot about
that and how by understanding the
pattern of the way emergence and
development occurs it broadens and
expands our control options away from
the proverbial you know pre-emergence
and and I'll talk a little bit about why
that concerns me alright let's do some
old-style slide stuff I have you know
from from the crumby from the archives
here a really simple slide about summer
annual weeds they germinate from seed in
the spring they grow through the summer
and they in the late season they flower
and prolifically prolifically 10,000
seedlings emerged in a lawn in Ontario
in a 10 square foot area 10,000 plants
emerged in a 10 square foot area in one
growing season and I'll show you some
data from our graduate student here now
an employee asset manager research and
asset manager out at the vineyard golf
club all right so if you don't put
pre-emergent herbicides down and you
disturb the soil and there's no
competition between the rows you get a
lot of weeds
look at what happens in these cabbage
broccoli plots where there was no
weeding performed at all and then you
look back at the plots here where some
pre-emergent control was applied and you
see when you really have no plant
competition look at the unfettered
emergence that will occur the soil is
especially at the surface is enormous ly
loaded with these weed seeds now when
you look at a lawn area and this is on
the campus here you see a pretty typical
pattern of crabgrass emergence number
one you see at first and foremost right
along the edges here of the sidewalk and
maybe where people Traverse right and so
you see walking over there maybe some
bare turf but then you see it
sporadically through the lawn and you I
know you can't see it very well but then
it's also dispersed more generally you
see it a little bit here there's gaps a
lot of this is gaps we got a steam line
here that keeps this soil really warm
and you can see the crabgrass just
absolutely loves that but a lot of times
we'll see crabgrass emerged out even
into the sparsely open lawn now one of
the things that we've learned is if
you've got a dense lon that's competing
with any grassy weed you tend to get a
lot of smaller plants many more smaller
plants because they're fighting for the
space and making their way through and
when they get up they really can't
emerge and get lateral plant grow
lateral leaf growth like a solar panel
but if you go to a bare area in
something like this that's been worn out
you can see individual plants that you
know are like salad plants they're like
you know toupees you can put on your
head and and it's one plant you know
that'll produce two to three thousand
seeds so so if if you have a dance lawn
you do not only get less weeds in some
cases not always sometimes you'll get
more we
but smaller and in larger areas you get
less weeds but bigger so you've got to
watch out the way you look at how plants
emerge and here's an example of what I
mean you know in a thin turf you can
already start to see you know some of
these plants getting fairly large right
you have to understand something let's
look at this plant right here let's look
at this plane right down here so here
you've got the first plant this is the
youngest leaf here firstly second leaf
look how it becomes more lateral when it
gets room and you know when a leaf can
get lateral like that man it's sucking
up the sunlight and producing and
getting big but let's get back to this
so this is the first plant here and then
this is a tiller one tiller two tiller
right so this is a 3 tiller plant 1 2 3
3 tillers right nice and easy this is
important because if your pries don't
work which I predict again they won't
like many haven't over the last several
years it behoves you to learn the growth
habits of these plants so that you can
then employ the post emergence
strategies alright so what is the DDD
tracker from Michigan State tell us
about crabgrass germination well it
tells us that we're still way behind if
you look at the color scheme here this
is a color scheme that indicates still
way behind oh sorry
let's go back so so we're still that
this color is behind normal this is
still early and this is primetime and
then there's another one that says you
know - it's all germinated so we're just
coming into this in the central jersey
area right now
pree merchants herbicides when you apply
them put a barrier in place but over
time that concentration goes from being
a well-established barrier right this
well-established barrier that as time
goes on degrade it breaks down it moves
through the soil it binds and ties
itself up there is some amount of
concentration that declines over time
that then brings it to a point where
weed seeds can germinate through it so
let's just do some basic stuff like
we've done before in general this line
with things like tenacity bail and
treflan is generally at best if you're
lucky it's six to eight weeks it could
be four to six weeks right where the
longer herbicides like barricade or
pendimethalin Pro diamine and dithiol
peer right you're now talking 12 to 14
weeks until you get to that degradation
right but if you put it on in April 6
let's say April May you know April May
June July that's 12 weeks there so April
so you're breaking down when are most of
them breaking down late July under
best-case if you put it on or you know
early April I mean that's your be lucky
if you make it to mid July let's keep
that in mind that this barrier gets
reached at different times now here's
when the same GDD tracker taught has
just told us we are way late if you
haven't put on your pre-emergent
crabgrass control in the metropolitan
New York area it's passed it's gone
you're really late in upstate New York
the Adirondacks would be the only place
and the northern reaches was the only
place it would still be good to have in
fact the ideal time was about three
weeks ago based on this tracker so even
you
these models sometimes can be a little
bit tricky now here's what's worrying me
really smart guys that I talk to on a
very regular basis who you know who's to
train other really bright people like
Matt Elmore are saying even with
pre-emergent herbicides his Bermuda
grass now obviously this Bermuda grass
gets inundated on the right here you see
goose grass problems beginning to emerge
out in Martha's Vineyard on some of the
sod we have out there a lot of our
herbicides don't work as well on goose
grass so let's get into some of these
emergence patterns right this is Mike
faux dances work from the early 90s
where he was looking at the emergence of
smooth crabgrass in College Park
Maryland now one of the things about
models that we're all getting used to
and curves that we're all getting used
to is that there's this period of time
where a time goes by and very little
happens and then BOOM you know community
spread happens right in this case it's
weed emergence and you get this very
rapid period of emergence and then it
sort of flattens off and a little bit
more still occurs up here right so you
don't get it all at once but it does
happen the majority of it happens over
about 200 days right about 200 days from
the first imir I'm sorry 200 base these
are bass I think these are bass 12c so
I'm not really worried about the
temperatures what I'm trying to say is
that there's a period of time that at
least in Maryland they showed in the
early 90s crabgrass emerges now in
Ontario Canada in 2009 they looked at a
smooth crabgrass emergence in lawns as
well and they found using a different
model that it behaved the similar way
but in the residential lawns that they
were looking at not in a research site
where you know we were they were
and at the way it emerged in gaps but
unreal lawns they showed something I
thought very interesting that that this
curve is even flatter right now let's go
back here for a second right now that we
know about curves right we've learned a
lot about curves that's a steep curve
which means it's happening really
quickly and the folks in Canada are
suggesting that it's a much more
prolonged germination again looking at
growing degree days over a period of
time and saying that you know your why
is this important it's important because
if you're pre-emergence breaks down here
right when 80% emergence has occurred
there's still 20% more than can come on
whereas if you just wait a little bit
longer let a little emergence occur
consider some strategies that could
include organic and biologicals then
then look at your pressure if you're not
getting a lot of pressure in the peak of
the season because your turf management
practices are going good or you decide
to do some post emergence there could be
other ways to go here all right what
have we learned
well my former graduate student Chris
set those out in Martha's Vineyard now
took samples on a golf course with a
history of crabgrass pressure sectioned
it out and wanted to see how much
crabgrass pressure we were getting from
the top one to two centimeters so what
is this this is half-inch the first
half-inch
right this is half to one inch right and
then this is deeper than wanted so we're
only talking about you know the shallow
part of the soil and we found crabgrass
concentrations or the amount of weed
seeds in the top half-inch in fact if
you got the top inch you've got 98% of
it now as Jo Ellen said 98% think of for
ticks and it's not great for crabgrass
but it does really give you a lot more
options with how you deal with it later
on now I'm not suggest
anyone go through and shave off the top
inch of their grout
Aaron Patton who we wanted to have with
us today has done a really nice job in
putting together a nice guide of the
different growth stages of smooth
crabgrass that are really good for you
to look at commit to memory and then
with Matt Elmore's control strategies
that he recommends at Rutgers and I
would encourage you to check these for
how they work in weather and their label
recommendations in New York but if
you're thinking about what I just talked
about about it get away
crabgrass emerges and releases and the
kinds of control strategies you can
employ you can see that there's a number
of programs that you can use a number of
products that you can use throughout the
season now check your labels and all the
things that's involved in this I'm not
making recommendations what I'm trying
to do is give you ideas for strategies
if by some reason you might expect your
crabgrass program to fall apart again
this year this is when you'll start to
see it during dry periods but look at
this is very fascinating that finally
fescue that's under drought stress there
you can see that there's something
that's preventing that crab grass from
growing in that finely fescue even
though it's drying out this is a patch
of finely fescue at a nursing home in
Westchester County and again I watched
it for a while that fescue is able to
keep out that crabgrass I don't want to
suggest it's a complete control but I
think it's the kind of thing we need to
think more about are there other ways to
control crabgrass than the blanketing
pre-emergent herbicides how about this
phenomenon that we observed high-traffic
areas like the one on the right here
where carts drive regularly crabgrass
doesn't grow in it can we provide some
traffic is there a way to create a
situation where the grass will grow and
the weeds will not and so with that Carl
I know I'm a little bit over but I'm
wondering if there are any questions
that came up either for the
picture from my little crabgrass rant
there yeah definitely some questions
about the crabgrass rich is asking a
good question about phenological
indicators so he's asking about the for
Cynthia at what stage in the for Cynthia
would that be a good indicator to to go
out and use your pre-emergent
application right and I purposely didn't
talk about phenological indicators
because in general they failed this year
they seem to be failing across the board
this year and I'm so glad you asked that
question again if you talk to Gerry
Giordano as we do every Thursday he was
telling us that forsythia was in bloom
in late March right we were talking
about for City in late bloom six weeks
ago in bloom and I think the bloom some
full bloom is considered the ideal time
to have your pre-emergence down now the
interesting thing about phenological
indicators in the Ontario study that I
cite they had a frost that completely
destroyed the bloom so that strips you
up I do like them as indicators but it's
not the BA it's not like you open it up
and it's you know this will happen every
time I think what we're learning about
indicators and models and predictions is
that they are informative tools that we
should ground-rule ike hey if it feels
early let me check the soil temperature
if the soil temperatures at 40 something
and this thing's blooming I don't think
crabgrass is gonna be germinating so it
seemed like the forsythia sat there for
four weeks in Westchester County I think
as Jeri reported as well so you probably
had four weeks to put it out if we were
using just that indicator what I'm
trying to get us to avoid is as soon as
you see the bloom run out and then
complain in mid to late June early July
when the lawns are full of crabgrass end
the crabgrass now has a competitive
advantage you got no options I'm arguing
for you know this is an important
decision that we've just given over to
the calendar or given over to an
indicator and really are not doing
enough of an understanding of the
weighted data
the way the plants behave because hello
we never had to cuz the technology works
so well and hello guess what it's not
working so well anymore so maybe it's
time to start thinking about this and
understanding this in a different way
yeah I'm in a ranting mood today so
Michael also has a good question he's
asking if you're gonna get greater
control by making smaller pre-emergent
applications but multiple apps so for
example applying kind of on the early
end of when you may apply it maybe a low
rate and then going back in it you know
you're saying some products may degrade
after four to six weeks or something
like speeding up the app what do you
think about that
well you know if if you're you know in
the lawn care and ground spins
especially in the lawn care operator
business right where it's very
production oriented they make you know
the majority of the income comes from
applying materials through as many lawns
as you possibly can keep as many
customers as you can you have to get it
done in a particular window historically
that window shrinks and you know gets
wider and narrower depending on weather
conditions there sometimes when you know
it's cool and then boom it's 80 degrees
and it's 80 degrees and the windows
really narrow and other years like this
year where the windows really wide all
right so let's talk about it set the
context if you were really early in the
window and you think you're going to
break down yes you should have some post
emergent materials available for control
that you use based on growth stage as
elmore suggests and you have them in you
know dithiol pierre and in phenoxy prop
and Inc Winkler act a little so so so
you have them they're not ideal have no
one's gonna say that a well time
pre-emergent isn't the best way to
control crabgrass no one should say that
some people would say well how about I
wait see how it comes up
I like tithe I appear or dimension I can
see it in the stage it's in behind me
here this is the three leaf stage I'm
sorry the 3 tiller stage you can you can
almost get some control with
therapy you can certainly get some post
control with meza trial and what I like
about them too Meza try own or the you
know compromise own pile ex their
pre-emergence activity is not very long
nor great for crabgrass but the thio
peer is really good too so the answer to
the question is you can either wait kill
the ones when they're young and in fact
there's some data from Matt Elmore that
shows high rates of iron those iron
chelate Slyke Fiesta can work on young
crabgrass
in the early part of the season and then
there's the options later on which
include you know once you get the five
chiller and Beyond you're at Quinn crack
and then there's this let me show you
then there's this weird growth stage
here right there's this weird growth
stage let's go to Aaron's thing here
there's this weird growth stage I think
I often hear Randy Pross that call it
the the teenage years I believe it's
somewhere in here in the three to five
leaf stage Quinn cleric or drive doesn't
work so up here you got dimension
you got Meza try own right um you've got
of course a claim you can I know people
that are clock PI a claim every two
weeks which is a good strategy for maybe
two or three years until your crab grass
becomes tolerant of phenoxy prop witches
which is likely to happen so so you have
a few early ones here you can use
dimension a little bit later and then
after here you're left with just a claim
and Quinn cleric or dr and really a
claim gets really expensive and not as
effective you really just left with
creme cleric and in new york state it's
hard to get the amount of quinn cleric
onto the plant that we need sometimes so
i have two long answer to how to use
post and pre-emergence together no it
did and and we did have one other
question about pH and if crabgrass
prefers a certain pH range
what do you know about that Frank well I
mean there is some evidence that crab
grass can grow at pH is below 5.5 for
example there is some evidence that it
does really well at eight five to ten
I've seen studies on chalk land pastures
in you know England but I think the rule
of thumb is this I don't show my
indication my suggestion is I don't know
that there's a particular pH that that
crabgrass is is is you know more aligned
to accept outside ranges we think our
grasses do well so I think the way to
look at pH is if your pH is limiting the
performance of your existing stand of
grass and that's your primary defense
for keeping annual grassy weeds out then
you want to make sure you're between
five five and seven five seven eight I
mean I don't think there's much you can
do when the pH gets too high I think you
have to accommodate some phosphorus and
iron things there and so that gets to be
really difficult but the low pH you
could lime up into five five if you're
above five five to six you're doing fine
and I don't see any reason why the
crabgrass would be more predisposed down
there all right
well looks like we got all the questions
today Frank again thanks for taking us
through some of the crabgrass stuff I
know it harkens back to you're in grad
school days that's must be why I got
excited I was all young again and and of
course Thank You Jo Ellen for the kick
information I've put some links for
everybody
about kick management options and also
to a webinar coming up I don't don't get
kicked New York that's on may 5th if you
want a webinar talking really more
in-depth about and then one last thing
before we go to the survey about these
webinars again for everybody so feel
free to check that out though that is
only a minute or two so back on the
survey give us feedback on the survey
very important you know six weeks have
gone by
we've done what have we done Karl we've
done 10 hours of total webinar stuff
across the three sectors over six weeks
well we're getting close to 20 webinars
here so we want to know is this of any
use because it's certainly interesting
to do it takes time of course and energy
and support to do and as it continues to
fill those needs we want to do it but we
won't do it unless you tell us that it's
really really stinks and here's how you
should make it better or it's really
good and you know keep doing it so
thanks Joelle and for joining us Karl as
always another great week in the books
see you see you guys this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu